Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Do you want to know what a pizza is? It is a focaccia made from leavened bread dough, which is toasted in the oven. On top of it they put a sauce with a little bit of everything when its colors are combined. The black of the toasted bread, the sickly white of the garlic, an anchovy, the greeny yellow of the oil and the fried greens, and the bits of red here and there from the tomato. They make a pizza look like a patchwork of greasy filth that harmonizes perfectly with the appearance of the person that's selling it. So that, Dominic, of course, was Halo Holodi, the author of The Adventures of Pinocchio.
感谢收听《历史的余味》。想要获取每周的额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你想知道什么是披萨吗？它是一种用发酵面包面团制成的佛卡夏面包，在烤箱中烤制而成。在它上面，他们会放上一层酱汁，当各种颜色混合在一起时，里面什么都有。烤面包的黑色、大蒜病态的白色、一条凤尾鱼、油和炒蔬菜的黄绿色，以及番茄随处可见的红色碎块。它们让披萨看起来像是一块油腻污秽的拼布，与卖披萨的人的外表完美融合。所以，多米尼克，那个人当然就是《木偶奇遇记》的作者哈洛·霍洛迪。
And he was writing in 1886 about something called pizza. Beautiful accent, Tom. Tuscan accent. Yeah, a Tuscan accent, which of course, people familiar with the various dialects of Italy will have picked up from my dropping of the hard C. Did you notice that, Dominic? I did. I did. Because Holodi was a son of a cook from Florence, wasn't he? So he took his food very seriously, took his Tuscan accent very seriously, and did not take pizza seriously. He despised pizza.
他在1886年写到了一种叫披萨的东西。口音很美，汤姆。托斯卡纳口音。是的，一种托斯卡纳口音，当然，熟悉意大利各种方言的人一定能从我省略硬音C中听出来。你注意到了吗，多米尼克？我注意到了。我注意到了。因为霍洛迪是佛罗伦萨一位厨师的儿子，不是吗？所以他非常认真地对待食物，非常认真地对待他的托斯卡纳口音，但并没有认真对待披萨。他鄙视披萨。
Dominic, what do you think he would make of the global success today of pizza? I think he'd be stupefied, wouldn't he? He'd be appalled. Do you think he'd be appalled? A patchwork of greasy filth. I mean, I think his position is quite clear, isn't it? I guess. I guess.
多米尼克，你认为他会如何看待今天披萨的全球成功？我想他会目瞪口呆，不是吗？他会感到震惊。你认为他会感到震惊吗？一块油腻污秽的拼布。我的意思是，我认为他的立场很明确，不是吗？我想是吧。我想是吧。
I mean, we are not the people to ask about this. But fortunately, we're joined on the podcast by an old friend of the rest of his history, the professor of Italian studies at University College London, John Dickey. Top Freemason expert. Top Freemason expert, but also the author of Delizia, the epic history of Italians and their food. John, welcome to the show. What did you make of Tom's Tuscan accent, first of all? Well, I take all the blame because of course I tried to coach him
我的意思是，我们不是回答这个问题的人。但幸运的是，我们邀请到了《历史的余味》的老朋友，伦敦大学学院意大利研究教授约翰·迪基来到播客。顶级共济会专家。顶级共济会专家，同时也是《美味：意大利人及其食物的史诗历史》一书的作者。约翰，欢迎来到节目。首先，你觉得汤姆的托斯卡纳口音怎么样？嗯，我承担所有责任，因为我当然尝试过指导他
in the rudiments of Tuscan pronunciation. But yeah, not a bad stab. Even my laziest students will be encouraged now by those efforts. So, John, we're very glad to have you back on the podcast, not least because your great claim to fame, apart from being a top historian of Italy, is that you're the only person who's listened to all 11 episodes of the series about Custer and the Sioux.
托斯卡纳发音的基础知识。但说真的，尝试得不错。即使是我最懒的学生现在也会受到这些努力的鼓舞。所以，约翰，我们很高兴你能回到播客，尤其是因为你除了作为意大利顶级历史学家之外，最大的名声就是你是唯一听完关于卡斯特和苏族人系列全部11集的人。
Or as they would say in Tuscany, Huster. Huster. It was, I loved it. The deep dive, the hour by hour narrative was excellent. Oh, this is very good. You can definitely come again. So, I mean, your book is The Epic History of Italians and Their Food, and we're going to be condensing that epic history into the next 45 minutes to an hour or so. I mean, an obvious point to make is that Italy, you know, it's a
或者正如他们在托斯卡纳所说的那样，胡斯特。胡斯特。它，我很喜欢。深入探讨，逐小时的叙述非常出色。哦，这非常好。你绝对可以再来。所以，我的意思是，你的书是《意大利人及其食物的史诗历史》，我们将在接下来的45分钟到一个小时左右的时间里浓缩这段史诗历史。我的意思是，一个显而易见的观点是，意大利，你知道，它是一个
language not just of regional dialects, or indeed, I guess you would have said regional languages before the 19th century, but regional cuisine. So is there even such a thing as Italian food? Yeah, I think there is. I mean, remember also that the regions are a relatively recent administrative invention in the 1970s, a lot of them. We're talking about much more complicated patterns of diversity than that. If you think of Naples, Naples is the capital of a whole kingdom, essentially carved out by the Normans in the 11th century. And that makes its cuisine have a different shape to the cuisine of, you know, the central areas of Italy or indeed Rome
不仅是区域方言的语言，或者实际上，我想你在19世纪之前会说是区域语言，而且是区域美食。那么真的有意大利食物这种东西吗？是的，我认为有。我的意思是，还要记住，这些地区是1970年代相对较新的行政发明，其中很多都是。我们谈论的是比那复杂得多的多样性模式。如果你想到那不勒斯，那不勒斯本质上是诺曼人在11世纪开辟的整个王国的首都。这使得它的美食与意大利中部地区，或者实际上是罗马的美食有着不同的形态
as the capital of the papacy. So even the idea of Italian food as regional is a very simplistic map. But I would say, yes, Italian food does exist. And it exists in the form of a kind of up by people in cities and kind of spread around the world. But you say that's not the case at all. There's a paradox here because I think one of the reasons why Italian food has become so successful is because Italians are so devoted to believing that kind of nonsense. Right. But there's really no evidence for it. You know, this sort of, you know, Italian peasants playing football in the Olive Grove version of Italian history. they tried to do was find out more about the peasantry and so on.
作为教皇国的首都。所以即使是把意大利食物视为区域性的，也是一张非常简单的地图。但我会说，是的，意大利食物确实存在。它以一种在城市中被人们所接受并传播到世界各地的形式存在。但你说根本不是这样。这里有一个悖论，因为我认为意大利食物之所以如此成功，原因之一是意大利人非常执着于相信那种胡说八道。对。但实际上并没有证据支持它。你知道，这种，你知道，意大利农民在橄榄树林里踢足球的意大利历史版本。他们试图做的是找出更多关于农民的信息等等。
It's a sort of avalanche of documentation over the next 60, 70 years, and it all comes to the conclusion that the peasants not only ate badly, but didn't even know how to cook the few things they had to eat. The fact that the average height of the Italian grew by four centimetres from the late 50s to the mid 70s, when the economic miracle happened and that long, long history of peasant hunger came to an end, tells you something about how we misperceive Italian food history. Just following up on that, cities in Italy go back to the Roman period. Is it possible to trace a history of Italian food back through the fall of the Roman Empire to the Roman period,
在接下来的60、70年里，这是一种文档雪崩，所有这些都得出一个结论，即农民不仅吃得不好，甚至不知道如何烹饪他们仅有的那点食物。从50年代末到70年代中期，当经济奇迹发生，那段漫长的农民饥饿史结束时，意大利人的平均身高增长了四厘米，这一事实告诉我们，我们是如何误解意大利食物历史的。接着这一点，意大利的城市可以追溯到罗马时期。是否有可能通过罗马帝国的衰落追溯意大利食物的历史到罗马时期，
or not really? I don't think so, because I tried to do it, and you can't. Remember, some of those cities, particularly in the South, are older. Messina is older than Rome itself and Naples and so on, the Greek cities of the Southern Islands. So what the classical world has bequeathed to contemporary Italy is what they call the hundred cities of Italy, these local Italian dishes that carry the names of cities. Pizza la Napoletana, Bistecca la Fiorentina, Risotto alla Milanese and so on and so on and so on. Parmigiano from Parma. That tells you something about the way that these cities produced foods and almost gave them a sort of urban branding as they were exchanged with other cities. That's where Italian food history happens. That's where the documents are and the stories and so on and so forth. So let's start with the first city you talk about, which actually is perhaps an unexpected city, which is Palermo, the capital of Sicily. So you kick off in 1154 in the reign of Roger II, the kind of Norman-Arab-Byzantine fusion
还是不太可能？我不这么认为，因为我尝试过，但你做不到。记住，其中一些城市，特别是在南部，比罗马本身还要古老。墨西拿比罗马、那不勒斯等还要古老，南部岛屿的希腊城市也是。所以古典世界留给当代意大利的是他们所说的意大利百城，这些带有城市名称的当地意大利菜肴。那不勒斯披萨、佛罗伦萨牛排、米兰烩饭等等等等。帕尔马的帕尔马干酪。这告诉了你一些关于这些城市生产食物的方式，以及当它们与其他城市交换时，它们几乎赋予了它们一种城市品牌。这就是意大利食物历史发生的地方。这就是文档和故事所在的地方等等。那么让我们从你谈到的第一个城市开始，这实际上可能是一个意想不到的城市，那就是西西里岛的首府巴勒莫。所以你从1154年罗杰二世统治时期开始，那种诺曼-阿拉伯-拜占庭式的融合
of Sicily. And you start here because this is the arrival of the one thing that everybody associates with Italian food, which is pasta, or rather dried pasta. So the fact that it's dried pasta, not fresh, that's the key, isn't it? Yeah, that's right. Pasta, which is not a word, you know, it just means dough or paste. And it only really comes to mean what we mean by pasta relatively recently. And what we mean by pasta includes all kinds of things like tortellini, which are little pies. That's what they mean. They're tiny little pies, filled pastas that are cooked by boiling. Lasagna. And all of these have different histories. But the one that is most, if you like, identified with Italy, even by Italians, is the dried variety, the stuff that fills supermarket shelves, made with durum wheat. And the first document that testifies to the arrival of that on Italian soil dates from
西西里岛。你从这里开始，因为这是每个人都与意大利食物联系在一起的东西的到来，那就是意大利面，或者更确切地说是干面。所以它是干面，而不是新鲜面，这是关键，不是吗？是的，没错。Pasta，这不是一个词，你知道，它只是意味着面团或糊状物。直到最近，它才真正开始意味着我们所说的意大利面。而我们所说的意大利面包括各种各样的东西，比如意大利饺子，它们是小馅饼。这就是它们的意思。它们是微小的馅饼，通过煮沸烹饪的填充面食。千层面。所有这些都有不同的历史。但最被意大利人，甚至被意大利人所认同的一种，是干面品种，那种装满超市货架的，用硬质小麦制成的。而证明它到达意大利土地的第一份文件可以追溯到
Roger II's reign in Palermo in 1154. And it comes from a geographer, Alidrizi was his name. He was an Arabic-speaking geographer, part of this extraordinary fusion court of Roger II, you know, with Greeks, Jews and Arabs and Normans moving together to run this kingdom. And he was the sort of one of the intellectual stars of this court. And he was commissioned to produce a planisphere, a great sort of silver domed map of the known world as a sort of advert for Roger's power and a book to go with it, which describes, you know, everything from the sort of desert islands of Scotland in the north to the sort of sandblasted unknown of Africa. And when he gets close to the Palermo capital, he starts obviously to get into more detail. And he goes to a place called Trabilla, which is just along the coast from Palermo, which is a centre famous
罗杰二世在1154年巴勒莫的统治时期。它来自一位地理学家，他的名字叫阿尔-伊德里西。他是一位讲阿拉伯语的地理学家，是罗杰二世这个非凡融合宫廷的一部分，你知道，有希腊人、犹太人、阿拉伯人和诺曼人共同管理这个王国。他是这个宫廷的知识明星之一。他受命制作一张平面球仪，一张巨大的银色圆顶地图，展示已知世界，作为罗杰权力的广告，并附带一本书，描述了，你知道，从北部的苏格兰荒岛到非洲那种被沙子吹过的未知之地的一切。当他靠近巴勒莫首府时，他显然开始进入更多细节。他去了特拉比拉，就在巴勒莫沿岸，这是一个以
for its springs and river courses. There he says that there is, and he uses the term factory, my Arabic is non-existent, but it's definitely a centre of large-scale production for export. Producing this stuff he calls ytria, and that is still used as an Italian word for a particular type of pasta called trie, and it is short bits of dried durum wheat spaghetti, which, according to this geographer, Ali Drizi, is made in huge amounts and exported all over the place, particularly all up and down the coast of Italy from Genoa right round to Naples and so on.
泉水和河流而闻名。在那里他说，有一个，他使用了“工厂”这个词，我的阿拉伯语不存在，但这绝对是一个用于出口的大规模生产中心。生产这种他称为“ytria”的东西，这在意大利语中仍然被用作一种特定类型面食的词，称为“trie”，它是短的干硬质小麦意大利面，根据这位地理学家阿尔-伊德里西的说法，它被大量制造并出口到各地，特别是沿着意大利海岸从热那亚一直到那不勒斯等等。
And that's where it arrives, and it arrives there from somewhere in the eastern Mediterranean that we don't know. There's a long history of noodles. Chinese noodles are thousands of years old. But if you really want to be terminologically specific about it, that's where pasta history really kicks off. So, John, you mentioned Chinese noodles. I mean, one of the most famous myths about Italian food is that actually pasta comes from China and is introduced by Marco Polo. But clearly, if it's originating in the United States because that story was actually invented for the first time by the Pasta Manufacturers Association of the United States in their industry magazine in 1929, this story, which then for some mysterious reason took off and got made into a movie in the 30s. And so with this pasta anecdote, and I think the reason there is they really wanted
这就是它到达的地方，它从我们不知道的东地中海某个地方到达那里。面条有着悠久的历史。中国面条有几千年的历史。但如果你真的想在术语上具体说明，那就是面食历史真正开始的地方。所以，约翰，你提到了中国面条。我的意思是，关于意大利食物最著名的神话之一是意大利面实际上来自中国，是由马可·波罗引入的。但显然，如果它起源于美国，因为那个故事实际上是美国面食制造商协会在1929年的行业杂志中首次发明的，这个故事，然后出于某种神秘的原因流行起来，并在30年代被拍成了电影。所以关于这个面食轶事，我认为原因在于他们真的想
to make pasta less Italian, so less greasy and Mediterranean and foreign and to make it more universal so they could sell more of it into the american market it was an italian produced pastor obviously and that was the origin of the story just looking through the books in the next chapters you turn north to the late medieval city states milan venice and so on you have a lot of stuff about different cookbooks or books describing the cities so there's's a book in Milan in 1288, there's a book in Venice, Libro per Cuoco in the mid-1300s. But they didn't really mention pasta particularly. So in Milan, it's all about fruit and vegetables.
让意大利面不那么意大利化，所以不那么油腻、地中海化和外国化，让它更通用，这样他们就能在美国市场上卖出更多。这显然是意大利生产的面食，这就是故事的起源。看看接下来的章节中的书，你转向北方的中世纪晚期城邦，米兰、威尼斯等等。你有很多关于不同食谱或描述城市的书。所以1288年米兰有一本书，14世纪中期威尼斯有一本《厨师之书》。但它们并没有特别提到意大利面。所以在米兰，全是关于水果和蔬菜的。
And in Venice, the big thing there are spices, obviously, because of Venice's position in the spice trade. So at that point, pasta is not at all emblematic of Italian cuisine specifically, is it? No, I don't think so it takes a long while to acquire that sense of signifying a place and a people and it starts to signify sicilians from about the sort of 15th century sicilians are known by other italians as mangia macaroni macaroni eatersaroni is the most widespread term for pasta, this kind of dried pasta in this period. And then it makes a very important transition we can talk about later to Naples. And Naples is really where it becomes hugely popular and emblematic. I mean, you find it even in medieval cookbooks in Britain. So it is travelling. And
而在威尼斯，那里的大事是香料，显然是因为威尼斯在香料贸易中的地位。所以在那个时候，意大利面根本不是意大利美食的象征，是吗？不，我不这么认为。它需要很长时间才能获得那种象征一个地方和一群人的意义，它开始象征西西里人，大约从15世纪左右开始，西西里人被其他意大利人称为“吃通心粉的人”。通心粉是这个时期这种干面最广泛的术语。然后它进行了一个非常重要的转变，我们稍后可以谈谈，到那不勒斯。那不勒斯确实是它变得非常流行和具有象征意义的地方。我的意思是，你甚至可以在英国的中世纪食谱中找到它。所以它在传播。而且
by the Renaissance period, it's in lots and lots and lots of recipes. I mean, one of the great themes of your book is people are always looking for authentic Italian food. You know, don't be like Jamie Oliver and put chorizo on a paella, that kind of thing. You know, you've got to get back to the original Bolognese recipe or pesto or whatever. And you point out what tosh this all is. So if you'd gone back to Venice for the original Venetian food, it's not kind of liver and onions, but it's more like Indian food, right? Heavily spiced, be like having a biryani or a korma or something. Yeah, no, absolutely. I mean, this is not just true of Italy, although Italy with Venice and so on is hugely important you know it's where europe
到了文艺复兴时期，它出现在很多很多的食谱中。我的意思是，你书中的一个伟大主题是人们总是在寻找正宗的意大利食物。你知道，不要像杰米·奥利弗那样在西班牙海鲜饭上放西班牙辣香肠，诸如此类。你知道，你必须回到最初的博洛尼亚肉酱食谱或青酱等等。你指出这一切是多么的胡说八道。所以如果你回到威尼斯寻找最初的威尼斯食物，它不是那种肝脏和洋葱，而是更像印度食物，对吧？香料味很重，就像吃印度香饭或咖喱一样。是的，不，绝对。我的意思是，这不仅适用于意大利，尽管意大利有威尼斯等等，非常重要，你知道，它是欧洲
gets its spices it's why venice became so rich yeah and they love their spices partly because of taste partly because it's got good snob value it's sort of food bling but they also love it for health reasons for galenic health reasons you know that this idea of balancing the humans. And right up to the sort of 16th, 17th century in Italy, this idea of spices with their heat balancing out the dangers of cold, wet foods is absolutely fundamental to the way food is thought about, to the link, which is a very ancient one, between food and medicine and food and improving your health and so on and so forth. So on that, you cite a Vatican librarian in the 15th century, Platina, who's an extraordinary man, and maybe we'll come to his career in a minute,
获取香料的地方，这就是威尼斯变得如此富有的原因。是的，他们喜欢香料，部分是因为口味，部分是因为它有很好的势利价值，这是一种食物炫耀，但他们也出于健康原因，出于盖伦式的健康原因喜欢它，你知道，这种平衡体液的想法。直到16世纪、17世纪的意大利，这种香料的热量平衡冷、湿食物危险的想法，对于人们思考食物的方式，对于食物与医学、食物与改善健康之间非常古老的联系等等，是绝对根本的。关于这一点，你引用了15世纪的一位梵蒂冈图书馆员普拉蒂纳，他是一个非凡的人，也许我们一会儿会谈到他的职业生涯，
but he's very interested in the idea that food can also be medical. So you quote him on bear meat, that it isn't good for the spleen or liver but can prevent hair loss so that's maybe something for dominic to bear in mind yeah thank you and also he's very very into aphrodisiac foods isn't he so he writes of dozens of ingredients and dishes that stir the libido from pine nuts to partridge from chickpeas to golden balls which we would call french toast broad beans stimulate lust because they look like testicles apparently onions taken in small doses arouse sexual appetite and increase its nourishment with lustful dampness. And oysters are valuable to the libidinous because they arouse even deadened passion. People still think that about oysters, but not about onions.
但他对食物也可以是医疗的这一想法非常感兴趣。所以你引用了他关于熊肉的话，它对脾脏或肝脏不好，但可以防止脱发，所以这也许是多米尼克需要记住的事情。是的，谢谢。而且他也非常非常喜欢催情食物，不是吗？所以他写了数十种激发性欲的成分和菜肴，从松子到鹧鸪，从鹰嘴豆到金球，我们称之为法式吐司，蚕豆刺激欲望，因为它们看起来像睾丸，显然，小剂量服用洋葱会激起性欲，并以淫荡的潮湿增加其营养。而牡蛎对好色之徒很有价值，因为它们激起即使是死寂的激情。人们仍然那样看待牡蛎，但对洋葱却不是。
No, they don't. So what's the librarian in the Vatican doing, going on about all this? He's a very, very interesting character. I mean, this is the pattern of my whole book. All too often, food historians who are essentially kind of cooks trying to be historians want to kind of break into these sources and sort of burgle them for come out with this amazing range of characters and stories which, yes, tell you about eating and largely how different it was, the different things it meant in the past, but also these characters like Platon, who was a humanist.
不，他们不那样看。那么梵蒂冈的图书馆员在做什么，一直在谈论所有这些？他是一个非常非常有趣的人物。我的意思是，这是我整本书的模式。食物历史学家通常本质上是试图成为历史学家的厨师，他们太频繁地想要闯入这些来源，并试图窃取它们，从而得出一系列惊人的角色和故事，是的，这些故事告诉你关于饮食，以及它在过去意味着多么不同，但也包括像普拉蒂纳这样的人物，他是一位人文主义者。
You know, humanists were these scholars of the classical world who invented the Renaissance as a narrative. Here it is, you know, it's saying to the guys in power in these newly wealthy Italian cities, if you hire us, we can teach you all the great lessons of the classical world and you can become as famous as Julius Caesar and whatever. And there will be a rebirth, a renaissance in Italian culture. And that's the narrative they sell. And his cookbook is very much in the lines of that narrative. He's saying, look, we can take on board all this classical learning.
你知道，人文主义者是那些古典世界的学者，他们发明了文艺复兴作为一种叙事。在这里，你知道，它是在对这些新富裕的意大利城市的当权者说，如果你雇佣我们，我们可以教你古典世界的所有伟大教训，你可以变得像尤利乌斯·凯撒一样出名等等。并且会有一个重生，意大利文化的复兴。这就是他们兜售的叙事。他的食谱非常符合那种叙事。他在说，看，我们可以吸收所有这些古典知识。
He borrows various sources from the classical world and shows off all his quotations and learned allusions. While also saying, well, actually, you know what? We can also do better than that. In the classical world, they didn't have blancmange. For example, we love our blancmange, which is not the blancmange that we know today. Blancmange is bianco mangiare, which is pounded capon and almonds,
他借鉴了古典世界的各种来源，并炫耀他所有的引语和博学的典故。同时也说，嗯，实际上，你知道吗？我们也可以做得比那更好。在古典世界，他们没有白酱。例如，我们喜欢我们的白酱，这不是我们今天所知道的白酱。白酱是“bianco mangiare”，它是捣碎的阉鸡和杏仁，
had to be made as white as possible white and yellow for purity they were the best possible things you could eat at the time tons of sugar tons of spices that was considered the ultimate in food refinement at the time and the sign that italy was now having sort of used the classical world as a launch pad, taking off into a new era of fame and greatness. Platinum was also a member of this obsessive secret academy of like-minded humanist scholars who got up to all kinds of things, having sort of toga parties and all that kind of stuff. Sounds great fun. Sounds like an absolute hoot.
必须做得尽可能白，白色和黄色代表纯洁，它们是当时你能吃的最好的东西，大量的糖，大量的香料，这在当时被认为是食物精致的极致，也是意大利现在已经把古典世界作为发射台，起飞进入一个名声和伟大新时代的标志。普拉蒂纳也是这个痴迷的秘密学院的成员，由志同道合的人文主义学者组成，他们做了各种各样的事情，举办托加派对等等。听起来很有趣。听起来绝对是个乐子。
Although the book is full of jibes against his mates, sounds like they weren't actually all that friendly and there was quite a lot of rivalry going on. That's just academics though, isn't it? Yes, exactly like that. And he subsequently got arrested for plotting to kill the Pope. And we still don't know whether there was any truth in this because when that Pope who arrested him died, he was made Vatican librarian
虽然这本书充满了对他伙伴的嘲讽，听起来他们实际上并没有那么友好，而且有很多竞争。但这只是学者，不是吗？是的，完全是那样。他后来因密谋杀害教皇而被捕。我们仍然不知道这是否有任何真实性，因为当那个逮捕他的教皇去世时，他被任命为梵蒂冈图书馆员
and he destroyed all the records relating to his trial and imprisonment. The book has a history of Italy through its food as much as it is a history of Italian food. That's why I enjoyed it so much. You get these stories that food becomes a doorway into. So John, could I just pick up on that? You say it was not until the Renaissance that Italians became aware they were eating in a style that distinguished them from foreigners. So what is it about the Renaissance that makes that? Is it to do with the
他销毁了所有与他的审判和监禁有关的记录。这本书通过食物讲述了意大利的历史，就像它是意大利食物的历史一样。这就是我为什么如此喜欢它的原因。你得到了这些食物成为入口的故事。所以约翰，我能接着这一点说吗？你说直到文艺复兴时期，意大利人才意识到他们吃的风格使他们区别于外国人。那么文艺复兴时期有什么特别之处使之成为可能？是因为
fact that they're looking back to classical exemplars? Is it because they're getting richer and they've got more material to work with? What is it that by this point is distinguishing them from other regions in Europe? They know that they're leaders in fashion, in European courts and so on and so forth. You remember your Chaucer episodes and how he goes to Italy and learns the latest in literary fashion from Dante and Boccaccio and people like that. You know, that's kind of happening with food as well. Remember, this is the European system of courts where this elite cuisine is being created that's quite international. And Italy is one of the engines of this. And of course, Rome, very important as well, because it's the international center of the papacy. And
他们回顾古典典范的事实吗？是因为他们变得更富有，有更多的材料可以利用吗？是什么使他们在这个时候区别于欧洲的其他地区？他们知道他们是时尚的领导者，在欧洲宫廷等等。你记得你的乔叟剧集，他如何去意大利并从但丁和薄伽丘等人那里学习最新的文学时尚。你知道，这在食物方面也正在发生。记住，这是欧洲的宫廷系统，正在创造这种相当国际化的精英美食。而意大利是其中的引擎之一。当然，罗马也非常重要，因为它是教皇国的国际中心。而且
in the Renaissanceissance the capital of italian food as a result you're talking about all the courts can we just go in the what i think is the best banquet in the book which is in ferrara in 1529 it's thrown by duke alfonso the first for his son ercole who's marrying the daughter of louis the 12th france and it's so long the list that we can only give a hint of the horrors so So 25 plates of boned capon coated in blancmange fried, then covered with sugar. 25 large white sausages with 104 fried sweetbreads sprinkled with sugar and cinnamon. 50 pieces of salted pike in yellow imperial sauce. Fried pigeons with slices of citron.
在文艺复兴时期，意大利食物的首都，结果你谈论所有的宫廷，我们能进入我认为书中最好的宴会吗，那是在1529年的费拉拉，由阿尔方索一世公爵为他的儿子埃尔科莱举办，他要娶法国路易十二的女儿，名单太长了，我们只能暗示一下恐怖之处。所以25盘去骨阉鸡，涂上白酱油炸，然后覆盖糖。25根大白香肠，配104个油炸甜面包，撒上糖和肉桂。50块咸梭子鱼，配黄色帝国酱。炸鸽子，配柠檬片。
257 pigeons in puff pastry. Here's the thing I'd never eat, 125 portions of eel in marzipan. So obviously this is bonkers to us because it's the mixture of sweet and savoury that we associate with kind of, as it were, old food. They didn't have the distinction. But the other thing to me is how it doesn't sound like your classic Italian food that everybody is familiar with. So would this at this point be, as it were, distinctively Italian, do you think? And obviously it bears no relation to what most people are eating. No. Italy was at this time, yes, a cultural concept, defined partly by the inheritance of the classical world and so on.
257只鸽子，配酥皮。这是我永远不会吃的东西，125份鳗鱼配杏仁糖。所以显然这对我们来说是疯狂的，因为它是我们与所谓的旧食物联系在一起的甜味和咸味的混合。他们没有这种区别。但对我来说另一件事是它听起来不像每个人都熟悉的经典意大利食物。所以你认为这在当时会是所谓的独特的意大利食物吗？而且显然它与大多数人吃的东西毫无关系。不。意大利在当时，是的，是一个文化概念，部分由古典世界的遗产等等定义。
But the food geography was still thought of, you know, it's a very ancient notion, the idea that some areas produce better produce of a particular kind. Talking about eels, Comacchio in the Po Delta is where those eels tend to come from. So when a duke is serving eels, is he making a kind of territorial claim on the region that they've come from? Is he showing he can source stuff from all over other lands? Is that a measure of his wealth and power? It's certainly the case that you have to show off and monarchs have always wanted to do that. I talked briefly about that mosaic from Theoderic's Ravenna, where Theoderic boasts about his ability to bring all four seasons to the table at once. That is the dream. That's the heart of the whole food sort of bling, the magnificence, to use the word of the day, of Renaissance courtly cooking. But eels were a huge practical necessity because, of course, one of the key things about
但食物地理仍然被认为，你知道，这是一个非常古老的观念，即某些地区生产某种更好的产品。谈到鳗鱼，波河三角洲的科马基奥是那些鳗鱼往往来自的地方。所以当一位公爵供应鳗鱼时，他是在对它们来自的地区提出某种领土主张吗？他是在展示他可以从其他所有土地采购东西吗？那是他财富和权力的衡量标准吗？当然，你必须炫耀，君主一直想这样做。我简要谈到了狄奥多里克拉文纳的那幅马赛克，狄奥多里克吹嘘他有能力一次将所有四个季节带到餐桌上。这就是梦想。这就是文艺复兴宫廷烹饪的食物炫耀、宏伟（使用当天的词）的核心。但鳗鱼是一个巨大的实际需要，因为，当然，关于
food in this period, and in Italy it's particularly obsessive, is the distinction between lean days and fat days, which has completely disappeared off our map. You know, the idea of there are days when you're not allowed to eat meat, it's more holy, it begins with monasticism in the sort of early centuries of Christianity. And that becomes this obsessive argument about it, you know, how can we get around this if we redefine things as fish they live in water okay do eggs count or not there's a whole complicated debate about this thing but eels throw out an absolute lifesaver for every table because the poor things can be just stored in barrels in a little bit of water.
这个时期的食物，在意大利特别痴迷，是斋日和肉食日的区别，这已经完全从我们的地图上消失了。你知道，有你不被允许吃肉的日子，它更神圣，它始于基督教早期几个世纪的修道院制度。这变成了一个关于它的痴迷争论，你知道，我们怎么能绕过这个，如果我们把东西重新定义为鱼，它们生活在水中，好的，鸡蛋算不算，关于这件事有一个复杂的辩论。但鳗鱼为每一张餐桌扔出了一个绝对的救生圈，因为这些可怜的东西可以被储存在桶里，加一点水。
They can be preserved easily and so on and so forth. So you have to jazz them up in every way you possibly can. And marzipan, though, really? I mean, that's like the single worst dish I think I've ever heard of until I got to the white sausages with sugar and cinnamon. Yeah, but I'd love to see something on ITV, you going around Italy, tasting eels in marzipan, resurrecting an enthusiasm for this kind of food, because there is a sense, isn't there, that as the Renaissance turns into the Counter-Reformation and the great powers of France and England and so on
它们可以很容易地保存等等。所以你必须以你能想到的每一种方式来装饰它们。但是杏仁糖，真的吗？我的意思是，那是我听过的最糟糕的菜，直到我看到加糖和肉桂的白香肠。是的，但我很想在ITV上看到你，在意大利四处走动，品尝杏仁糖鳗鱼，复兴对这种食物的热情，因为有一种感觉，不是吗，随着文艺复兴变成反宗教改革，法国和英国等大国崛起，
kind of rise to a greater supremacy, that Italian food as well as culture is seen as going slightly into abeyance. And is that because a supremacy in food for Italy is an expression of its culture? Yeah, at a courtly level, there's no question that Italy is marginalized from the 16th century. It becomes the sort of plaything of the great powers and court cultures. Fashions are driven further north, particularly Paris.
某种程度上上升到更大的霸权，意大利食物以及文化被视为稍微进入了中止状态。这是因为意大利的食物霸权是其文化的表达吗？是的，在宫廷层面，毫无疑问，意大利从16世纪开始被边缘化。它成为了大国和宫廷文化的玩物。时尚被进一步推向北方，特别是巴黎。
And it's from Paris that food fashions are revolutionized and changed. And really, we wouldn't have modern Italian cuisine without the influence of France. There's no question about it. And then, of course, you also get the new world foods arriving. You know, the shift on the center of gravity of the world economy from the Mediterranean to the Atlantic means the arrival of all of these foods, which take a long time to bed down. You know, Italians, it takes them a long time to work out what to do with tomatoes, for example, before they make it onto pizza and pasta and chocolate and things like that. Although they make quite an early appearance in Italy and southern Italy, a lot of it ruled by Spain, there's a whole food revolution this point. And when we come back, let's look at how that revolution happens, how pizza and other such dishes that are now so well-known
正是从巴黎开始，食物时尚被革命化和改变了。真的，没有法国的影响，我们就不会有现代意大利美食。毫无疑问。然后，当然，你也有新世界的食物到达。你知道，世界经济重心从地中海向大西洋的转移意味着所有这些食物的到来，它们需要很长时间才能沉淀下来。你知道，意大利人，他们需要很长时间才能弄清楚如何处理番茄，例如，在它们进入披萨和意大利面以及巧克力等东西之前。尽管它们在意大利和意大利南部很早就出现了，大部分由西班牙统治，这一点上有一场全面的食物革命。当我们回来时，让我们看看那场革命是如何发生的，披萨和其他现在如此出名的菜肴是如何
come to take on the form that we would recognise. We'll be back in a few minutes. Bentonato, everybody. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking Italian food and what it says about Italian history with Professor John Dickey. And, John, let's turn to a city we haven't really mentioned at all, or at least we've only mentioned in passing, which is Naples. So Naples in the 1700s is by far the biggest city in Italy.
开始呈现我们所能识别的形式。我们几分钟后回来。欢迎回来，大家。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在与约翰·迪基教授谈论意大利食物及其对意大利历史的意义。约翰，让我们转向一个我们根本没有提到，或者至少我们只是顺便提到的城市，那就是那不勒斯。所以18世纪的那不勒斯是意大利最大的城市。
And in your chapter about Naples, you place us with the Lazzaroni. Am I getting that right? They'd previously been broccoli eaters, but now they're rebranded macaroni eaters for their love of pasta. What is it about Naples and pasta? Why do we associate Naples specifically with pasta at this point? Yeah, this dried pasta tradition really has its capital in Naples and still does to this day. But that's a transformation. I'm Marina Hyde.
在关于那不勒斯的章节中，你把我们放在了拉扎罗尼（Lazzaroni）身边。我没说错吧？他们以前是吃西兰花的人，但现在他们因为对意大利面的热爱而被重新命名为吃通心粉的人。那不勒斯和意大利面有什么关系？为什么我们在这个时候特别把那不勒斯与意大利面联系起来？是的，这种干面传统确实在那不勒斯有其首都，并且至今仍然如此。但那是一个转变。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《历史的娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开了娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集、
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com, head to therestisentertainment.com That's therestisentertainment.com ...that really happens in the 17th and 18th century. Remember beforehand it was Sicilians, because this is where Jerome Wheat was grown in Sicily
以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com……这确实发生在17和18世纪。记住，在此之前是西西里人，因为这是硬质小麦在西西里种植的地方
and so on, who were known as Mangia Maccheroni, macaroni eaters. But that nickname switches to the Neapolitans, who stop being what they called leaf eaters or leaf shitters, which is their previous nickname when they ate meat with various varieties of broccoli. And they become Mangia Maccheroni because this megalopolis of early modern Naples has this vast rabble that needs feeding. Remember, Naples is, unlike a lot
等等，他们被称为“吃通心粉的人”。但那个绰号转移到了那不勒斯人身上，他们不再是他们所说的“吃叶子的人”或“拉叶子的人”，这是他们以前吃肉配各种西兰花时的绰号。他们变成了“吃通心粉的人”，因为这个早期现代那不勒斯的大都市有这群庞大的乌合之众需要喂养。记住，那不勒斯，不像很多
of the rest of the kingdom, a huge city capital of a vast and ancient kingdom. And it has to deal with an era of mass politics and mass city life and finds pasta the way to do that, an easy way to feed the masses. And it can be made easily in places like Granano and so on just down the coast. But it has a hugely important cultural and symbolic meaning in this period as well. And like you say, it's associated with the Lazzaroni. This is the era of the Grand Tour. And everybody who goes to Naples has to have a theory about who these Lazzaroni are.
王国其他地方，是一个巨大的城市，一个庞大而古老的王国的首都。它必须处理一个大众政治和大众城市生活的时代，并发现意大利面是做到这一点的方法，一种喂养大众的简单方法。它可以在像格拉尼亚诺这样的地方很容易地制造，就在海岸边。但它在这个时期也有着极其重要的文化和象征意义。正如你所说，它与拉扎罗尼联系在一起。这是大巡游时代。每个去那不勒斯的人都必须对这些拉扎罗尼是谁有一个理论。
These are guys who loaf around in rags in the sun. This is where the idea of the dolce fargnente comes from, this languorous existence of happy poverty that these guys are supposed to embody. And the great mental image from the period of them is them eating spaghetti, as we would call it now, macaroni, with their hands, dangling it into their mouths. And the king himself does that, doesn't he? And the king himself does that, doesn't he? And the king himself does that. He even does it at the opera. King Ferdinand, who was in power for an awful long time between the late 18th and early 19th centuries, the Lazzaroni, were basically a kind of proletarian elite loyal to the monarchy who exercised a kind of protection racket over the political system. They were the monarch's sort of
这些是在阳光下穿着破烂衣服游荡的家伙。这就是“无所事事的甜蜜”这个想法的来源，这些家伙被认为体现了幸福贫困的慵懒存在。那个时期关于他们的伟大心理形象是他们用手吃意大利面，我们现在会这样称呼它，通心粉，把它悬挂在嘴里。国王本人也这样做，不是吗？国王本人也这样做，不是吗？国王本人也这样做。他甚至在歌剧院也这样做。费迪南德国王，他在18世纪末到19世纪初掌权了很长一段时间，拉扎罗尼基本上是一种忠于君主制的无产阶级精英，他们对政治系统行使了一种保护费。他们是君主在
representatives among the rabble. This macaroni came to symbolise this bond between the monarch and the masses, who the Lazzaroni were sort of chiefs of. And that's what Ferdinand was doing. It was his language of absolutism, if you like. Whereas Louis XIV builds Versailles, he eats macaroni with his hands to establish this bond with the masses. And who gets to keep his throne, I guess. Yes. What are they eating the pasta with? Not tomato-based sauces at this point? No, largely pork fat. The tomatoes don't arrive until quite
乌合之众中的代表。这种通心粉开始象征君主与大众之间的这种纽带，拉扎罗尼是其中的首领。这就是费迪南德在做的事情。这是他的绝对主义语言，如果你愿意的话。路易十四建造了凡尔赛宫，而他用手吃通心粉来建立这种与大众的纽带。我想，谁能保住他的王位。是的。他们用什么吃意大利面？在这个时候不是番茄酱吗？不，主要是猪油。番茄直到
a lot later. So the pork fat, we don't associate that at all with Naples. That's kind of Bologna or somewhere. Why did that die out? Well, just fast forwarding quite a lot, we associate Italian food and Italians associate Italian food with the Mediterranean diet. La dieta mediterranea, that's the great watchword of contemporary Italian cuisine. The Mediterranean diet was actually invented by an American scientist in the 1950s. So basically everything seems to be invented by Americans. From the late 19th, early 20th century, something crazy like sort of seven and a half million Italians emigrate to the New World.
晚得多才到达。所以猪油，我们根本不把它与那不勒斯联系起来。那是博洛尼亚或其他地方。为什么它消失了？嗯，只是快进了很多，我们将意大利食物和意大利人将意大利食物与地中海饮食联系起来。地中海饮食，那是当代意大利美食的伟大口号。地中海饮食实际上是由一位美国科学家在1950年代发明的。所以基本上一切似乎都是美国人发明的。从19世纪末、20世纪初，大约有七百五十万意大利人移民到新世界。
And the cultural exchange there, back and forth, not even to mention episodes like the Second World War and so on, has a huge influence on Italian cuisine. This particular scientist, Ancel Keys, was his name. He was the one who invented the K-rations that American troops had in the Second World War. And it was an epidemiologist working on the link between animal fats and cholesterol and heart attacks and stuff. And in order to kind of monetize his academic research, which is something, of course, I'd thoroughly disapprove of, he and his wife wrote this cookbook that they branded as the Mediterranean diet in the 1970s. And that's how it took off. But, of course, he says it himself. This isn't the Mediterranean diet in the 1970s. And that's how it took off. But of course,
那里的文化交流，来来回回，更不用说像第二次世界大战这样的事件等等，对意大利美食产生了巨大的影响。这位特定的科学家，安塞尔·基斯，是他的名字。他就是发明了美国军队在第二次世界大战中使用的K口粮的人。他是一位流行病学家，研究动物脂肪与胆固醇和心脏病等之间的联系。为了将他的学术研究货币化，这当然是我完全不赞成的，他和他的妻子在1970年代写了这本食谱，他们将其品牌化为地中海饮食。这就是它流行起来的方式。但当然，他自己也说了。这不是1970年代的地中海饮食。这就是它流行起来的方式。但当然，
he says it himself, this isn't a Mediterranean diet because we've completely taken pork fat out of it and all of these other elements to make it look more like the kind of thing we associate with Italian food today. So they're having their pasta and their pork fat, but they are not having pizzas in Naples. Well, they are having pizzas, but they're not like the pizzas that we know. So they have a thing which is like a kind of focaccia. The word probably related to the Greek word for pita and the Turkish word pide. That's where it comes from, I'm guessing. We're guessing, yeah.
他自己也说了，这不是地中海饮食，因为我们已经完全去掉了猪油和所有这些其他元素，使它看起来更像我们今天与意大利食物联系在一起的那种东西。所以他们吃着意大利面和猪油，但他们在那不勒斯不吃披萨。嗯，他们吃披萨，但它们不像我们所知道的披萨。所以他们有一种东西，就像一种佛卡夏面包。这个词可能与希腊语中的“pita”和土耳其语中的“pide”有关。我想这就是它的来源。我们在猜，是的。
The thing is flatbreads. People putting discs of dough onto hot stones, you know, that's so ancient that what's specific about it sort of vanishes into nothing almost. But it does in the 19th century start to become associated again with this culture of eating in the street of these ragged Neapolitan masses. And that's where people start to observe it in the middle of the 19th century. Alexandre Dumas, the Three Musketeers author, is one of the first people to pick it up. And there we do start to get traces of tomato as well as bits of anchovy and stuff. It's just a flavouring. And it's very, very much associated with the low city of Naples, the poorest, most overcrowded quarters of the city. And it's street food, but not in a good way. Can I ask you then about probably the most famous of all pizzas, the pizza margarita, which is actually named after a queen, isn't it? So how does that come about? Okay, Naples in the 19th century inspires horror and disgust because of cholera. Cholera arrives in Europe in
事情就是扁面包。人们把面团圆盘放在热石头上，你知道，那太古老了，以至于关于它的具体东西几乎消失了。但在19世纪，它确实开始再次与这种在那不勒斯破烂大众街头饮食的文化联系起来。这就是人们在19世纪中期开始观察到它的地方。《三个火枪手》的作者亚历山大·仲马是第一批注意到它的人之一。在那里，我们确实开始得到番茄的痕迹，以及凤尾鱼碎块等等。它只是一种调味品。而且它非常非常多地与那不勒斯的低层城市联系在一起，城市中最贫穷、最拥挤的地区。它是街头食物，但不是好的那种。那么我能问你关于所有披萨中最著名的玛格丽特披萨吗，它实际上是以一位王后的名字命名的，不是吗？那么它是怎么来的呢？好的，19世纪的那不勒斯因为霍乱而引起了恐惧和厌恶。霍乱在欧洲到达了
I think 1820s, 1830s, and Naples, because of its hygienic conditions, its overcrowding, its poverty, and so on, so on, is particularly vulnerable to it. I think there are something like eight outbreaks in the 19th century. And that's why nobody would dream of eating pizza. We began with the quote from Carlo Collodi, the author of The Adventures of Pinocchio, who, again, wrote about pizza. And he wasn't remotely the only one. It's something absolutely abhorrent and disgusting and associated with the city of Naples. And there was a huge outbreak of cholera in 1884 in Naples, very, very politically dangerous moment. The wealthy, the middle classes just abandoned the city. And the king of the day, King Umberto, with his wife, Margherita, went to the city. Actually, Umberto I, Margherita, went a couple of days later when they were kind of rebuilding the city to build on their popularity naples has always had a kind of monarchical feeling about it that
我认为19世纪20年代、30年代的那不勒斯，由于其卫生条件、过度拥挤、贫困等原因，对霍乱特别脆弱。我想19世纪大约发生了八次疫情。这就是为什么没人会想到吃披萨。我们从《木偶奇遇记》作者卡洛·科洛迪的引言开始，他也写过关于披萨的内容。他绝不是唯一一个。披萨在当时被视为一种绝对令人厌恶、恶心的东西，并与那不勒斯这座城市联系在一起。1884年那不勒斯爆发了大规模霍乱，这是一个非常危险的政治时刻。富人和中产阶级纷纷逃离城市。当时的国王翁贝托一世和他的妻子玛格丽特王后去了那座城市。事实上，翁贝托一世和玛格丽特是在几天后，当城市开始重建时才去的，为了提升他们的声望。那不勒斯一直有一种君主制的情结，这
continued for a long time and part of margarita's image she was a highly fashionable you know there was even a fashion magazine named after in the period she She was a real lifestyle leader. And it seems that pizza acquired its name, Pizza Margherita, that is, around that time as a sort of city's homage to these monarchs who had actually visited the city in its hour of need. Isn't there a story that there's one guy, Rafael Esposito, who runs a bakery in the Spanish Quarter and he makes three pizzas? One with whitebait, one just with olive oil, and one with the classic mozzarella. And she liked number three, and that's how it got the name.
持续了很长时间，这也是玛格丽特形象的一部分。她非常时髦，当时甚至有一本以她名字命名的时尚杂志。她是真正的生活方式引领者。披萨玛格丽特（Pizza Margherita）这个名字似乎就是在那时出现的，作为这座城市对这些在危难时刻造访的君主的一种致敬。难道没有一个故事说，有个叫拉斐尔·埃斯波西托的人在西班牙区经营一家面包店，他做了三种披萨吗？一种是银鱼的，一种只放橄榄油的，还有一种是经典的马苏里拉奶酪的。她喜欢第三种，这就是它得名的由来。
Is that true or is that an urban myth? That's another complete fake story, I'm afraid. One of the many, many. I mean, writing Italian food history is really like machine- gunning anchovies in a tin. You know, there are so many of these myths around. And that is one of them. Unfortunately, there is the Pizzeria Brandi, a famous pizzeria in Naples, which has this letter, which is supposedly original of Queen Margarita saying thank you for these lovely pizzas. And that's a fake.
这是真的还是都市传说？恐怕这又是另一个彻头彻尾的假故事。这样的故事数不胜数。我的意思是，撰写意大利饮食史就像在罐头里用机关枪扫射凤尾鱼一样。你知道，周围有太多这样的神话了。这就是其中之一。不幸的是，那不勒斯有一家著名的披萨店Pizzeria Brandi，他们有一封据说是玛格丽特王后亲笔写的感谢信，感谢这些美味的披萨。那是伪造的。
Are you personally, are you able to visit Italy? There's not an embargo against you or something, like stamping on all these. Right. Yeah, you've got the Masons getting you. Now you've got Italian foodies. Yeah, I know. Those who've read the book will know it's got a higher body count
你个人能去意大利吗？他们没有对你实施禁运或者类似的事情，比如封杀你之类的吧？对，没错。你有共济会盯着你，现在又有意大利美食家盯着你。是的，我知道。读过这本书的人会知道，它的死亡人数比我写的黑手党历史还要多
than my history with the Mafia. This book, Dilettù, got made into a TV series in Italy, a six-part series, me presenting in it. Seemed to go down very, very well. I don't know why, but it's since become much, much more controversial because one of the dogs that didn't bark of Italian food is people pinning political identity to Italian food. And that's begun to happen with the current fascist nostalgic government trying to use this idea of Italy's traditional Mediterranean peasant food. Which you're saying is an American idea?
这本书《Delizia》在意大利被拍成了电视连续剧，一共六集，由我担任主持人。看起来反响非常好。我不知道为什么，但它后来变得非常有争议，因为意大利饮食中一个被忽视的现象是人们将政治身份与意大利食物挂钩。而这在当前的法西斯怀旧政府中已经开始发生，他们试图利用这种意大利传统地中海农民食物的理念。你是指这其实是一个美国概念？
Completely. So irony is piled on irony? Yeah, absolutely. So could I just ask you about the attitude of the fascists, so the original fascists, Mussolini, to to food because he's actually not particularly interested in at all no no the fascists didn't like food they ideally would have reduced the italian diet to olive stones and gristle if they could have done the idea was that these italians there's new spartans or something marching to a new Mediterranean empire.
完全是。所以这是讽刺之上的讽刺？是的，绝对是。我能问一下法西斯分子，也就是最初的法西斯分子，墨索里尼对食物的态度吗？因为他实际上对食物一点也不感兴趣。不，法西斯分子不喜欢食物，如果可以的话，他们宁愿把意大利人的饮食缩减为橄榄核和软骨。他们的想法是，这些意大利人是新斯巴达人，正向着一个新的地中海帝国进军。
And, you know, Mussolini, he had a gastroduodenal ulcer, which tortured him for most of his political life. And he didn't like being photographed eating, preferred to be the sportsman and so on and so forth. They tried to promote rice. They had a battle for grain as, you know, this idea of self-sufficiency of Italian food production under fascism in preparation for this war that they wanted from the beginning. And Italian food, particularly pasta, just didn't fit into that because one of the terrible secrets of Italian pastries would be pretty much impossible to have an Italian pasta culture on the scale without importing grain from places like the Crimea. You know, Garibaldi had played his little role in importing grain from the
而且，你知道，墨索里尼患有胃十二指肠溃疡，这折磨了他大半个政治生涯。他不喜欢被拍到吃东西的样子，更喜欢表现得像个运动员等等。他们试图推广大米。正如你所知，他们进行了“谷物之战”，这是法西斯统治下意大利粮食生产自给自足的理念，为他们从一开始就想要的战争做准备。而意大利食物，特别是意大利面，根本不符合这一点，因为意大利面食的一个可怕秘密是，如果没有从克里米亚等地进口谷物，就不可能维持这种规模的意大利面食文化。你知道，加里波第在19世纪初当水手时，曾在进口谷物方面发挥过一点小作用，
Crimea in the early 19th century when he was a sailor. But the fascists do invent the idea of the cult of the rural housewife with her traditional recipes, don't they? So that's where that comes from. That's the first time that we do start to get a bit of sort of rustic eating nostalgia there are all kinds of rustic pastoral forms of poetry and opera and so on going on before that but there's really very very little trace of anybody being crazy enough to associate eating well with the countryside before the fascists start to do it. But even their efforts weren't terribly convincing. You know, they put on a big show in Rome and set up this sort of rustic village, so-called in the Circus Maximus in Rome
但他确实发明了农村家庭主妇及其传统食谱的崇拜理念，不是吗？这就是它的来源。这是我们第一次开始感受到某种乡村饮食的怀旧情绪。在此之前，各种乡村田园诗和歌剧等形式一直存在，但在法西斯开始这样做之前，几乎没有任何人会疯狂到将吃得好与乡村联系起来。但即使是他们的努力也不是特别令人信服。你知道，他们在罗马举办了一场盛大的展览，在罗马大竞技场建立了一个所谓的“乡村村庄”，
as part of an exhibition of fascist culture in 1938. But of course, this rustic village had all of these cuisines from Rome, from Venice, from Milan. It's an urban picture of Italy as what it is, a collection of urban cuisines. And so basically what happens then, I'm guessing, is that it is an urban idea of what the countryside should be that then starts to shape the countryside to conform to this urban vision is that what happens yeah it starts to happen once you reach the plenty in the post war period the economic miracle italy goes very very rapidly from being a peasant society to being an industrial society in the late 50s 60ss, 70s. And really, the 1970s are a key decade in this. It's a very difficult decade for Italy. It's the years of lead, of
作为1938年法西斯文化展览的一部分。但当然，这个乡村村庄包含了来自罗马、威尼斯、米兰的所有菜肴。这是意大利作为城市菜肴集合体的一种城市图景。所以我猜，后来发生的事情是，这是一种关于乡村应该是什么样子的城市理念，然后开始塑造乡村以符合这种城市愿景，是这样吗？是的，一旦你在战后时期达到富足，这种情况就开始发生了。意大利在50年代末、60年代、70年代非常迅速地从农民社会转变为工业社会。事实上，70年代是其中的关键十年。这对意大利来说是非常困难的十年。那是“铅色年代”，是
terrorism, and all that kind of thing. The state feels corrupt. And also of environmental crises of various kinds. And it's in this period in the 1970s that you start to get rustic food nostalgia. And the idea of Italian food is this collection of ancient peasant traditions, almost all completely invented. That's when that rustic nostalgia really hits home. And you get inventions like the biscuit brand, Il Molino Bianco, the white mill. Yeah, which is just totally fabricated. So I wanted to ask you about one person that you zero in on here, which is Giovanni Rana, if I pronounced that correctly.
恐怖主义等等。国家感到腐败。还有各种环境危机。正是在70年代这一时期，你开始感受到乡村食物的怀旧情绪。而意大利食物是古代农民传统集合体的理念，几乎全是完全虚构的。那是乡村怀旧情绪真正深入人心的时候。你得到了像饼干品牌“Il Molino Bianco”（白磨坊）这样的发明。是的，那完全是捏造的。所以我想问你关于你在这里重点关注的一个人，乔瓦尼·拉纳（Giovanni Rana），如果我没读错名字的话。
Yeah. He is the tortellini magnate. So tortellini, if I understand you correctly, was a Sunday food. You had it on Sundays and you had it in a broth and the sort of little pass, almost like dumplings, I guess. And he takes that and he makes it a convenience food with huge factories and stuff. But also the key to it is his marketing. Is that right?
是的。他是意大利饺子（Tortellini）大亨。所以，如果我没理解错的话，意大利饺子曾经是一种周日食物。你在周日吃它，把它放在肉汤里，就像饺子一样，我想。他把它拿过来，通过大型工厂等把它变成了方便食品。但关键在于他的营销。是这样吗？
That he markets himself. I mean, this is what people miss out completely with this rustic traditions version of Italian history is the commercial genius that is behind contemporary success of Italian food. Tortellini are medieval. They're very ancient. They're these little pies, and medieval people loved a pie, that you cook by boiling, mini pies.
他推销的是他自己。我的意思是，这就是人们在意大利历史的乡村传统版本中完全忽略的东西，即意大利食物当代成功背后的商业天才。意大利饺子是中世纪的产物。它们非常古老。它们是这些小馅饼，中世纪的人喜欢馅饼，你通过煮来烹饪，迷你馅饼。
So they're very ancient. And, you know, there are recipes right back into those medieval cookbooks we talked about earlier. By the post-war period, period prosperity, this sort of Sunday lunchtime treat in the brief historical existence of the classic Italian housewife. This is what they become in the post-war period. They've come from being part of the peasant labor force, moved into cities. I'm generalizing massively, obviously.
所以它们非常古老。而且，你知道，早在我们之前谈到的那些中世纪食谱中就有这些食谱。到了战后时期，繁荣时期，这种周日午餐的享受，在经典意大利家庭主妇短暂的历史存在中，这就是它们在战后时期所变成的样子。她们从农民劳动力的一部分，搬进了城市。显然，我是在进行大规模的概括。
And then they get pushed into education and into the labor market again. And people can't make those things anymore. Whether they don't have the skills or most certainly they don't have the time. And Giovanni Rana in the late 60s, 70s, 80s seizes onto this. Because tortellini present a huge problem of trust what is in the filling you can put any old muck in there if you want yeah you've got to have trust and he puts his face on the packet his signature on the packet to translate that trust into the era of vacuum packing and urban living and supermarket distribution and all that kind of thing and they've become a huge success and if you buy packet tortellini from sainsbury's or whatever it is in britain they're almost certainly made by giovanni rana so john
然后她们再次被推向教育和劳动力市场。人们再也做不出那些东西了。要么是他们没有技能，要么肯定是没有时间。乔瓦尼·拉纳在60年代末、70年代、80年代抓住了这一点。因为意大利饺子存在巨大的信任问题，馅料里是什么？如果你愿意，你可以往里面放任何垃圾。是的，你必须有信任，他把自己的脸印在包装上，把他的签名印在包装上，将这种信任转化为真空包装、城市生活和超市分销的时代，等等。它们取得了巨大的成功，如果你在英国的塞恩斯伯里超市或其他地方买包装好的意大利饺子，它们几乎肯定是由乔瓦尼·拉纳制造的。所以约翰，
can we just end as you said you've been um shooting anchovies in a tin here. There seem very few myths left. And yet there is a sense that there is something distinctively appealing to a frenetic modern world about Italy and Italy's food culture, the idea of slow food. Is it all just marketing and American influence and whatever? Or is there something genuinely true about it, despite everything that you've been saying? I think that that connoisseurship that is associated with urban living in Italy, that we get developing the Middle Ages, wider selection, people learning the manners and connoisseurship that go with good eating that communicates itself and is in position when people do have the resources then to rediscover and exploit these traditions you know all kinds of advertising flummery about peasant traditions and the slow
我们能结束了吗？正如你所说，你在这里一直在“扫射罐头里的凤尾鱼”。似乎剩下的神话很少了。然而，有一种感觉，对于一个狂热的现代世界来说，意大利和意大利的饮食文化，即“慢食”的理念，有着某种独特的吸引力。这仅仅是营销和美国的影响等等吗？还是说尽管你说了这么多，它仍然有某种真实的东西？我认为与意大利城市生活相关的鉴赏力，我们在中世纪发展起来的，更广泛的选择，人们学习与美食相伴的礼仪和鉴赏力，当人们有资源去重新发现和利用这些传统时，它会传播开来并占据主导地位。你知道，关于农民传统和慢食的所有广告噱头，
food case is that language that that process turned into politics, effectively, the politics of food. Carlo Petrini, a great friend of our current king, is the founder of this movement, found in the 80s as a sort of rebellion against fast food and the commercialization of food. So it's in Italy too, because the memory of peasant existence really wasn't that, you know, it was only a generation ago. The Italians start to capitalize that in a commercial way with the kind of commercial know-how. So the myths are mostly entirely mythical, but they do in a sense misapprehend the history which they can then put to very good commercial use and the fact remains i mean you've got a statistic in your book that there are 10 times fewer fast food outlets burger outlets or whatever in italy
就是将那个过程转化为政治，有效地转化为食物政治。卡洛·佩特里尼（Carlo Petrini），我们现任国王的好友，是这一运动的创始人，在80年代作为对快餐和食物商业化的一种反叛而创立。所以它也在意大利，因为对农民生活的记忆真的没那么久远，你知道，那只是一代人之前的事。意大利人开始以商业方式利用这一点，并具备商业头脑。所以这些神话几乎完全是虚构的，但它们在某种意义上误解了历史，然后可以将其用于非常好的商业用途。事实仍然是，我的意思是，你的书里有一个统计数据，意大利的快餐店、汉堡店或其他类似场所的数量比英国、法国或德国少10倍。
than there are in britain or france or germany so italy the outliers i was thinking about what makes it a difference and i guess you could argue what makes Italy different is that it always had that network of cities and that that was the distinctive thing about it. France obviously has Paris and it has other major cities, but it doesn't have quite the same competitive world of city-states. Is that the thing? Is that what makes Italy different?
所以我一直在思考是什么让意大利与众不同，我想你可以说意大利的不同之处在于它一直拥有那个城市网络，而这正是它的独特之处。法国显然有巴黎，也有其他主要城市，但它没有像意大利那样竞争激烈的城邦世界。是这个原因吗？这就是让意大利与众不同的地方吗？
Yeah, I think so. Italy's long food history, most Italians simply weren't a part of for so long. Nevertheless, we have the sort of aspirations and a model for sophisticated eating, urban living, which is still very strongly felt in Italy. This sense of living amid these ancient stones and these artistic treasures and food has been kind of bolted onto that. I mean, I should say that Italy is vulnerable to a lot of these trends. Apparently, Italians now eat more sushi per head than anybody else in the world. And I don't know why it is that sushi made such a big impact in Italy, but Italians absolutely love it. You know, John, the peak delicacy in the Roman period for the elite was to eat kind of fish
是的，我想是这样。意大利漫长的饮食历史，大多数意大利人长期以来根本没有参与其中。尽管如此，我们仍然有对精致饮食、城市生活的向往和模式，这在意大利仍然非常强烈。这种生活在古老的石头和艺术珍宝之中的感觉，而食物已经以某种方式与此挂钩。我的意思是，我应该说意大利很容易受到许多这些趋势的影响。显然，意大利人现在人均食用的寿司比世界上任何其他国家的人都多。我不知道为什么寿司在意大利产生了如此大的影响，但意大利人绝对喜欢它。你知道，约翰，罗马时期精英阶层的顶级美味是吃那种几乎是生的鱼，
that was almost raw because you could only have it if it was fresh from your ponds or whatever. So it was an absolute marker of status. So perhaps it's a reversion to their very ancient ruins. I like to think that that's what it is. Anyway, John, thanks so much. That was absolutely wonderful. And it's lunchtime now.
因为只有当它是从你的池塘里新鲜捕捞出来的时候，你才能吃到它。所以这绝对是一个地位的标志。所以也许这是对他们非常古老的遗迹的一种回归。我喜欢认为这就是原因。总之，约翰，非常感谢。这真是太棒了。现在是午餐时间了。
I might pop out to Brixton Hill and go to Pizza Brixton, upholding the Dolce Vita in South London. So John's book, as a reminder to you all, is Delizia, the Epic History of Italians and Their Food. John, brilliant to have you back on the podcast. At some point, we'll definitely have you back to do the Mafia so that you really can block your copybook in Italy. Just to say, you know, anyone who's going to Italy, it's an absolutely wonderful book to take and read. thanks so much for coming on and thank you all for listening bye-bye ciao bye-bye goodbye i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment
我可能会去布里克斯顿山（Brixton Hill）的Pizza Brixton，在伦敦南部弘扬“甜蜜生活”（Dolce Vita）。所以，提醒大家一下，约翰的书是《Delizia: The Epic History of Italians and Their Food》。约翰，很高兴你能回到节目中。在某个时候，我们一定会请你回来讲讲黑手党，这样你就能真正地在意大利“留下污点”了。只是想说，你知道，任何要去意大利的人，这绝对是一本值得带去阅读的好书。非常感谢你的到来，也谢谢大家的收听。再见，再见，再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。